all they want is to get out some of them
have been waiting for days at Paolo
Airport to get on one of the planes that
are bringing in the aid Indonesia's
armed forces are constantly airlifting
in relief goods things that people here
need most water food medication most of
all and on the way back they're taking
those who are desperately waiting to
leave old people people who are injured
people have lost their homes women and
small children and I'm about to give
birth that it's difficult to still get
treatment at the hospital here so I have
to go to a bigger city in the city
rescue workers find new bodies every day
the earthquake has extinguished entire
neighborhoods
this is the end of a landslide that's
about two kilometers long and that was
caused by the earthquake and to
understand the shear force that was
unleashed you just have to look at that
building up there because that
previously wasn't here but some 100
meters down in that direction and it was
swept here by the moving soil now there
are still some five hundred people
believed to be buried here and a lot of
the people over here on this side have
lost relatives right here and they're
waiting for them to be found
Irwin lost his mother his brother and
his nephew when solid earth turned into
a swirling vortex when the ground
started moving I went outside the whole
street rose up it was like a wave and we
were swept away it was like a hole
opening up and then slamming shut again
yeah
it will take Paulo and its residents a
long time to recover from what was
destroyed in just a matter of seconds
and some wounds may never heal